لاول مره دعوه قضائيه في مدارس امريكيه ضد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والتهمه التسبب
بازمه نفسيه لدى الاطفال الدعوه اكدت ان
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي خلقت مصدر ازعاج
عام من خلال استهدافها للاطفال عبر
منصاتها الاتهام تضمنت القاء المسؤوليه
على منصات السوشيال ميديا في تدهور الصحه
العقليه والاضطرابات السلوكيه والسعود
وصعوبه تعلم الطلاب الدعوه اشارت الى ان
المنصات اجبرت المدارس على توظيف متخصصين
اضافيين في الصحه العقليه وتطوير خطط
الدروس حول تاثيرات وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي المزيد حول الموضوع مع علاء
سرحان
مع اكثر من
3.6 مليارات مستخدم حول العالم اصبحت
وسائل التواصل وسيله قويه لمشاركه الافكار
مع الاخرين لكنها ايضا اصبحت مصدر توتر
وقلق بالنسبه للملايين خصوصا لدى
المراهقين وفقا لمركز بيول الابحاث فان
81% من المراهقين في الولايات المتحده
يستخدمون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الابحاث
تؤكد ان واحدا من كل سته مراهقين يتعرضون
لاشكال من السلوك المسيء عبر الانترنت
كذلك فان المعهد الوطني للصحه العقليه في
الولايات المتحده يؤكد ان نحو 22% من
المراهقين سيعانون من ضعف عقلي حاد في
حياتهم بسبب هذه الوسائل فيما يؤكد
استطلاع ان تسعه بالمئه من كل عشره
مراهقين يؤكدون ان التحرش عبر الانترنت
يمثل مشكله للاشخاص
في سنهم فيما يفيد نحو 24% من المراهقين
انهم يعتقدون ان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لها تاثير سلبي بشكل عام عليهم
[موسيقى]
ومن ابو ظبي ينضم الينا استشاري طب
الامراض النفسيه الدكتور سامر مخول صباح
الخير دكتور سامر يعني السؤال البديهي
الاول هل يسمح لاداره المدارس حجبه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مع العلم انها قد تكون
احيانا سبل للتعليم او للاكاديميه
صباح النور وشكرا على الاستضافه بالذات
بهالموضوع كتير مهم وكمان فرصه لنقول كل
عام بخير لكل الامهات بالوطن العربي هلا
هذا الموضوع كتير رغم عنا نعم الوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هي واقع عنا يعني انا
دائما كنا نقول لا فينا نستعمل ما فينا
نستعمله هو واقع بدنا نتعامل معه في كتير
سيئات بس في ايجابيات فينا نستعملها يعني
نحن لازم نحاول ناخذ ايجابيات ونخفف
السلبيات مثل ما انتم بالموضوع في تاثير
كثير كبير على الحاله النفسيه والامراض
النفسيه عند المراهقين تحديدا دكتور هلاك
ان تخبرنا عن بعض الحالات اللي اجتك في
العياده سواء من كبار او من صغار وما هي
يعني كم ساعه يعتبر بعد ذلك هو ادمان يعني
هل ساعتين باليوم طبيعي ام يعني ما هي عدد
الساعات اللي بعد ذلك قد يعتبر ادمان او
خطر
ما في عدد ساعات معينه بنعتبره انه هذا
ادمان الادمان نحن انه الشخص اللي ما
بيقدر بدون الماده المدمنه بعطيك مثال
مثلا بالليل يتاكد انه في عنده اي لايك او
اي مسج على الوسائل التواصل اللي ما بيقدر
يتركب بيتطلع كل اكثر واكثر اذا حددنا
ساعتين او ثلاثه يمكن يكون هذا نصيب بحد
ذاته ادمان وفي ناس بتكون عندهم اكثر ماثر
على حياتهم دكتور سامر يعني شفنا
مؤخرا لانه يوجد كنترول او السيطره من قبل
الاباء على ساعات ادمان الطفل على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هل هذه الفكره ناجحه
ممكن يكون هذا يعني
يحرر الطفل من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هذا شيء ضروري هذا واجب على كل اهل يعني
الاهل يلي ما يسيطروا على الاستعمال
الوسائل تواصل الاجتماعي لاطفالهم هذا
بيكون نوع من الاهمال وليس نوع من والله
الجهلانين وما بيعرفوا لا لانه هذا واجب
علينا لانه بده يوقفه على المخاطر طبعا
لازم نحدد الساعات كل التكنولوجيا الحديثه
بتساعدنا لحتى يكون في شيء اسمه
للاطفال يستعملوا اي شيء له علاقه
بالانترنت مثلا ساعه معينه للصباح مشان ما
ياثر على نموهن على تطورهن على هذا الشيء
فطبعا لازم نحدد من وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بسبب المشاكل الصحيه اللي
ذكرناها قبل يلي بنلاقيها كل يوم بيجوا
لعندنا في كثير
تبع الشخص بشجعوا بعض الامراض مثل
الاناركسيا مثلا بيعلموهم كيف
اجتماعي في كثير مشاكل عم تصير معنا طيب
دكتور ليه واعرف يعني
شخص ذهب لانه كان يلعب جيمز هوايه فهل
هناك مثل هذه المساحات بالعالم العربي
اللي هي يعني مثل الادمان الوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي او للعب على الالعاب
الالكترونيه
شوي مختلفين الادوان الالكترونيه غير
الوسائل
نحن حتى صار في عنا تشخيص عالمي لالهم
اللي هو ادمان مثل الادمان العاليه مثل
الادمان المخدرات مثل هذا الشيءة للواحد
بتوقف حياته ما بيقدر يوقف عليه
وهو اكثر شيء خلينا نقول سايبولوجي نفسي
اكثر انه في عندي نوع
من الحماس اللي انا ما بقدر اتركه عالميا
طبعا في عندنا بعض المساحات اللي عم تتابع
مع هذا الشيء وحتى محليا من الشغلات اللي
بتساعد فيها بعض الاطفال او الناشئين مو
دائما في داعي يدخلوا على المصحات بس في
بعض المصحات بالعالم العربي سمع ت انه عم
تعالج هذا الشيء يعني
العلاج خلال فتره ما بيتعامل مع مثل
الادمان مثل الادمان الاقمار مثلا حتى نعم
استشاري الطب الامراض النفسيه الدكتور
سامي المخون شكرا جزيلا لك